joining us now is Ed Knight syed's
attorney her name is Erica Suter Erica
good morning to you listen even just
hearing the music from the podcast said
ding ding dink brought me all back to
this case because I followed it from the
very beginning listening to the podcast
serial and I kept going back and forth
back and forth and the more I listened
to it the more I was convinced an
injustice had been done here so I don't
want to say how is he feeling I'm sure
he's over the moon but I want to know
the moment that he got the news
yesterday what that was like for you and
his team
um well good morning thank you so much
for having me it was a wonderful moment
I was able to face time with him and
tell him what happened and he was just
incredibly grateful incredibly happy I
think he was he was standing up and he
said he needed to sit down you know to
process the information he always comes
from a place of gratitude and he's just
thankful to all the people who have
supported him
he does come from a place of gratitude
and at one point correct me help me
remember this wasn't he at one point
offered a plea deal and he refused it
he was back in 2018 when his case was
pending before the court of appeals he
had already won a new trial twice and he
was offered a plea deal but he would
have had to admit this crime he would
have had to plead guilty and say that he
was guilty of this and he wasn't willing
to do that
now they're they're DNA testing was it
not available back then is that is that
what has led to the change today why
we're at this place
well there's a number of factors and
sort of the lead factor in vacating this
conviction was that there was evidence
that someone else made a threat against
the victim that wasn't turned over and
under the law that sort of information
has to be shared with the defense so
that you have a fair opportunity to
defend yourself so that's really sort of
what's at the heart of this but there's
also DNA testing there's testing that's
been done in 2018 and the additional
testing that was done more recently and
again and again and again of this
testing none of it connects to Adnan and
the most recent testing although there
was DNA from other people actually
excluded him
and what do you say to people I'm
thinking about Heyman Lee's family
because listen they lost a beloved
daughter here so they are still very
much in pain that people that say listen
justice has not been served who still
May doubt whether Anon is is is innocent
to the family of Hayman Lee Adnan and I
continue to express our deepest sympathy
this was somebody that was a non-friend
this was somebody that he cared about
and it's not it's never been lost on
Adnan the suffering of her family and we
all have to understand that their entire
world has been abandoned they've
believed this one thing for all of this
time and now their world has shifted and
that's one of the major problems with
wrongful convictions is sort of that
ripple effect that impacts the victim's
family that impacts the public that
impacts the accused family it has really
wide reaching effects I know I keep
thinking about that family today but I'm
also thinking about finally justice has
been sir for odd and on it can you tell
us a little bit about him like what were
his plans before this before he was
accused of this crime he's 17 years old
he seemed to be a very popular kid in
school what were his plans his dreams
he was 17 years old he was a sweet kid
he was accepted into college he planned
on majoring pre-med he planned on
becoming a doctor so he's you know right
in sort of the middle of his life at the
very beginning when we're all figuring
out you know who we're going to be what
kind of adult we're going to turn out
and you know he was he was snatched from
his family and incarcerated for these
for these past 23 years yeah and you
can't get those 23 years back what are
his plans now does he even know
so much has changed in the world well he
what
of course
um he wants to continue his education
it's very important to him he had the
benefit of actually being able to begin
a Georgetown education while he was
incarcerated through the Georgetown
Scholars Program and it's very important
to him that he finishes his Georgetown
degree he also has dreams of going to
law school
all right he has a lot of people
cheering him on Erica Suiter we thank
you for your time today really
appreciate that thank you so much